les chefs d'entreprise en général
veulent retravailler c'est très
important de pouvoir reprendre
il est vrai que la jauge des 50% sur les
terrasses a quand même rebâtir les
projections que les restaurants se
faisait 50 % d'une terrasse il faut
savoir que le chiffre d'affaires et 30 %
donc vous diminuer de 50% et ensuite
nous ne ferait qu'un seul service du
gros diminué de 50% latine 10% du
chiffre d'affaires envisagé c'est assez
difficile je ne suis pas sûr que
l'ensemble des restaurants pourront
rouvrir dans ces conditions non les
commerces ont été très bien préparé il
s'en sont alors 3e réouverture donc
effectivement tous les protocoles sont
en place les jauges ont été fixées donc
huit mètres carrés pour 1 pour un client
sans compter le personnel dans les
commerces et on compte sur la
bienveillance des clients pour
comprendre de ses chefs d'entreprise
sont responsables de faire respecter ces
règles
la chambre de commerce elle est toujours
présente tout au long de la ve est
particulièrement dense est dans cette
période
on sait aujourd'hui par expérience que
le numérique puisque sa grande entrée
dans nos nouvelles habitudes de
consommation et on engage vraiment tous
les commerces qui hésitent encore à se
diriger vers nous avec le chèque
numérique pour les accompagner pour leur
expliquer que ce soit pour un click and
collect que ce soit pour un ou place de
marché y participer on est là pour les
accompagner
c'est vrai qu'il ya plein plein de deux
structures qui ont été mises en place
pour les accompagner dont la structure
au zoo avec du tutorat pour les écouter
parce que je pense qu'il faut pas
oublier qu'un chef d'entreprise est très
seul et qu'il a besoin aujourd'hui de de
se sentir soutenu et ils ont besoin de
d'encadrement on se rend disponible on
peut se déplacer on sait aussi écouter
sans aucun jugement